The raft is secure, but I can't reach them over radio their comms must be down. What's your status?
Already here
URI I thought you said it was secure it was let's go
Maybe it's not as bad as it looks
Love the optimism but in my experience when it looks bad, it's usually worse
Look out
Hold on
You okay yeah
Welcome to the park just in time for the fireworks
Looks like we made parole boy
Electro, why is he letting everyone out? I'll head for the main control center and see how bad the situation
Got it. I'll go join the party
Everyone just quietly go back into your cells and lock the door behind you
Like fishing a beer that doesn't sound good
Oh
Hi RINO
Hope you like surprise spider
Surprise, what is he talking about?
Hey
Me just trapped in a prison with every criminal I put away in the last eight years. No biggie
Electrum must be working for someone
This is too good to be true
Scorpion. Can you hold on a minute? I was in the middle of a phone call and it was business
Don't let up
Lost you, please check it there you okay. Not really
Electro Rhino and now scorpion are all on the loose what's going on in the rest of the prison?
Camera systems almost done. I'll give you a sitrep soon. Okay, I'll keep tracking Alexa
Come on spider-man I thought this was a shake gotta stop this guy
If you tell me who you're working for I'll go easy on you can't stock it but up planet that you still try
Nobody ever takes me up on that offer
Vulture long time no see we're gonna have so much. Sorry no time to talk
Okay, I got the security cameras back online, how's it look
Well, it looks like the entire population of the rap game
That makes five of your worst enemies that are now on the loose
For a second there. I thought you were serious. I am serious. I'd have to go some of them are heading into the city
Keep chasing parties almost dark
Electro stop
How do you like my new suit dashing, where'd you get it? It's an exclusive club
Remember he said not to kill him good idea. In fact, we don't have to do this at all
If you don't want to we definitely want
You
Hey everybody its Charlie so we finally got more spider-man ps4 footage. It was Sony's press conference at e3
So there was obviously a whole bunch of other games if you're brand new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos they'll be giveaway stuff that I'll explain at the end of the video
But the whole idea is that in this universe, it's an older version of Peter Parker
The kingpin has been sort of controlling the city, but he gets put behind bars
So he jokes to Peter Parker that he kept a certain amount of order in the city
So even though the kingpin is a spider-man villain
He had a way of keeping the city working from completely eating itself alive when he gets thrown in prison
It leaves a power vacuum for another villain to rise that villain is mr. Negative
You've seen him in a couple of the other trailers before
Martin Lee is sort of his other
aspect a friend of Peter Parker's so that's why when this sort of new version of the sinister six is beating the crap out of
Him on top of the raft here and you see this white light flash and it says oh my gosh
It's you the whole thing about that is that it's probably one of his friends because one of mr
Negatives abilities is manipulating the dark force and bringing out the evil in people so he can change people's alignment
So he could turn what a Peter Parker's friends into a villain
That's probably why he's staring into this white light at the end of the trailer going. Oh my god
It's you like he couldn't believe that somebody would turn on him
So we just get to see some of the gameplay mechanics some of his midair combos. It's spider-man
So obviously he's gonna have a bunch of midair combos, but you have upgraded versions of electro rhino scorpion vulture. Mr
Negative hasn't been a really big character in the movies so far
I love the way that Yuri says that five of your most dangerous villains have escaped the raft and he jokes
Ah, haha, you know why don't we make it one more and we'll make it an even sinister six
So the whole idea of this over narrative is that you have this giant raft prison break
So all the most dangerous spider-man and Marvel villains escape in in New York City spider-man has to take them down
But the big villain to be taken down is mr. Negative. But the thing is is that his friend the other aspect of mr
Negative is Martin Lee that he's trying to save so it's not one of those
Situations where you could just kill the villain and solve all your problems
Plus pending instant kill mode spider-man isn't really hot on killing people
So just let me know what you think of the footage so far, but obviously this is going to be coming out in Sept
So there's gonna be a whole bunch of comic-book stuff happening, then we'll learn a little bit more about the other stuff
That's gonna be drop, you know comic book related at Comic Con this summer
But it looks really badass and obviously it's like a really big arkham style open-world game
So there's butch a side quest they'll be dlc
I'm sure so there's a whole bunch of stuff that we haven't seen yet in the latest big costume bonus that they just released was
The iron spider costume after infinity war so they'll be a bunch of other costume reveals coming up, too
Since this game is coming out pretty soon. I'll do the giveaway for this game
So obviously all you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
But click here for brand new infinity war and click here to learn all about jeff jones doing the new green lantern corps movie
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight